welcome back to another episode of the
iced coffee hour this one is probably
gonna be the most exciting because uh a
few reasons so you know macy and i are
coming up on three years of wednesday do
you believe in three years what are you
gonna do
well
show you
right
here
no
way
is that what i think it is it is you
want to open it jack what's that
you're like graham are you serious yeah
wait what is this
what do you think oh don't don't say
where it's from but
i should have put it in a tiffany box
dude it's so real just like you what do
you mean
like i'm just like i don't know i can't
mention that
yeah
are you serious yeah
i thought you knew jack i talked to you
how did you not know
i've
i can't tell if jack is acting because
i've like i've mentioned i've talked to
you about this yeah but you're just a
gym but you're the person who mentions
things like subtly yeah i know i kept up
with it more because i see you more than
jack but you're the type of person that
like mentions it but then like unless
somebody like asks you about it you
don't mention it again yeah it's like
that's kind of true it's like seeing
this yeah in person
guys look at this
yeah you know this is um
let's talk about this this is pretty
small for a millionaire
yeah so for those of you who are
listening to the podcast uh yeah graham
pulled out a ring box and uh but you
know i could show it yeah well yeah but
some people are listening on spotify oh
yeah i'll whip it out but anyway
um yeah mace actually mentioned this one
and uh it's smaller so it's not like so
like over the top but it's opal and a
little diamond
so i think opal is cooler
try it on jack yeah try it out yeah can
you put it on me yeah there you go
practice all right so this dude this is
so amazing no it doesn't fit
holy cow i can't believe this
congratulations yeah seriously i'm
excited this is so cool so tell us tell
us the plan man what tell us what do you
got planned what are you going to do run
us through yeah we're not going to be
there so we got to know yeah
dude this is crazy
oh my god oh my god
so yeah so
yeah i usually don't get like too
personal and stuff like this but we we
had our first kiss at the top of the
ferris wheel the santa monica pier
so i thought that would be the time to
do it at the top of the ferris wheel
but
i was asking alex kind of like went over
this plane with alex
there's no way to photograph that i told
him that you know if it was kelsey she'd
want it like at least photograph at
least when she gets down
um and i'm like dude why didn't you have
me come with her why don't you get a
photographer uh you know i'm not don't
you don't need to video it but i think
that macy would love to have photos
later on in life to look back on on the
day that she got proposed just put a
gopro in the thing or tell call the
ferris wheel people ahead of time and
tell them to put a camera somewhere or
go there the day before you can do it a
hundred percent there's nobody but but
the ferris wheel rotates around yeah
and we'd have to be at the precise
moment in line so it doesn't look
like it's set up because you basically
wait in a line and then one comes down
and one person gets in and one comes
down one person yeah but i'm sure if
that because you said the the cards fit
multiple people yeah i'm sure that if
you coordinate something with a
photographer and a ferris wheel company
to just have the photographer get in
line with you and they know that they're
supposed to like let them in on your
cart no but they don't let other people
in on your cart i thought you said more
people fit than just like they do if
you're in if you're in the same party
yeah you don't want to be in there with
someone else either no you can't you too
i didn't know how big they were no i
mean they're big enough where it's like
a group of five would be able to fit oh
but they don't i thought it was like the
like you know you can fit like 10 people
in it's no it's the size of the table
okay so it's like super awkward if
there's another person yeah no i could
always just set up a phone on a tripod
or just like
put a phone on the other side it'll be
obvious i'm filming
yeah
but like there's no other spot that
would make logistical sense i mean i
think as long as you at least take some
pictures when you get down
yeah alex's idea was to have somebody on
the ground taking pictures like secretly
like macy hates anything public like
that so i wouldn't want to make like a
big deal in public with that so it would
have to be like a hidden photographer to
show pictures like
late you do have a telephoto lens i do
but it doesn't have to be a hidden
photographer like like it could just be
like a friend like like coming up like
hey guys yeah i'd love to take some
pictures you know you go over here
nobody's like no i would say i would say
it's got to be like a like a hidden sort
of deal she wouldn't i know her she
would not want to draw attention to
herself in the middle of the santa
monica pier and then get a photographer
with a telephoto lens yeah yeah and then
you know that way it's kind of like at a
distance and
i don't know okay but then again if
you're not posing for it and you're
coming off of the ferris wheel
yeah you just have to know that okay
they're over here and you have to face
it do you have a telephoto lens i do
have you happen to have one i do i could
i could always get your plane ticket if
you want to come down there and wait i
want to go yeah you come too someone's
got to watch the fish tank though is
andrew going to be here no
he's coming oh i'll have jeremy i'll
have jeremy do it it'll be fine
if you want you could do something okay
yeah all right i can be there just for
the pictures sure okay i don't know how
uh that's on wednesday i've never been
wednesday night i've never been to this
pier i don't know how big it is but you
where we can scott i can scout it out
with you you would be able to do it you
guys would be able to do it oh and then
the surprise afterwards is that uh we're
getting dessert but her family's gonna
be there at the desert
you're gonna have a table at the desert
place i can't believe this dude
that is so cool yeah thanks
you know what's funny when we're just
talking about
uh relationships and prenups and stuff
with judge fonda bee yep
good old timing good old yeah great
timing yeah yeah oh my god dude so how
do you feel what's your overall
sentiment towards it are you nervous
excited like uh both
both nervous and excited do you think
she'll say yeah
i don't know that's the scary part 50
50. i could go either way at this point
i don't know so
let's let's talk about um
something that i'm sure everybody's
wondering yeah so i kind of mentioned
that that ring is not not too big you
know most people expect that when you're
a little bit successful in life and
again this is just like the common thing
people think of not i didn't follow it
certainly and i know tons of people who
didn't um
there's no like it's not a traditional
wedding ring first of all and um there's
no giant diamond that can cut people in
the face
so um where did that come from well she
picked it out really right yeah yeah she
was hinting she's been hinting uh by
like sending like pictures and like oh
doesn't this look pretty grandma i'm
looking at it like that
but she's not she doesn't like the crazy
expensive things i think knowing her if
it were if it were over a certain price
or like a certain size it would just be
like intimidating you'd worry about it
uh this is something i think it's
understated and i think that's
way better to have something that's like
not crazy plus i like that like i
wouldn't be
it's like
your watch isn't like this big flashy
watch like i get what you mean yeah
there's no no one knows anything but
it's classic yeah yeah exactly that we
did the same thing with with my wedding
ring it's not expensive enough for me to
get like insurance on it or anything
yeah um
it's very inexpensive but kelsey still
freaks out like just because she's that
type of yeah yeah but if now if she
loses it it's not like but i think opal
is way more unique than a diamond i
agree so and nobody else has it it's
like the yellow tesla roadster how many
other people have the yellow tesla roads
you want something that that not a lot
of other people have and opal is one of
those just different so i like that so
jack uh
you're next man
oh man we got a long ways to go man oh
we could get there we could get there i
i'm honestly i i feel like i can't how
am i supposed to continue the podcast
how do we talk about business man that's
all i can think about no no no no is
there anything else you want to say i
got other topics to talk about i'm just
happy for you dude i think that's so
cool and um i i will try to make it out
there cool yeah yeah yeah the scariest
part though is asking for her dad's
blessing oh yeah
oh my god i mean i knew his answer was
gonna be yes but it was just like really
scary to like her mom had to get her
like her mom had to get everyone out of
the house
because like there's never a time that
i'm alone with your dad yeah yeah and uh
her brother didn't want to go with them
everyone's like hey we should go out and
do this everyone's like yeah let's do
that and her dad because she knew her
dad wouldn't want to go to this place
and so her dad's like no i'll stay here
and her brother was supposed to come
along and it's like no i'm just gonna
stay home
and so like he wanted to watch motocross
or something and uh like any anywhere we
would go like he kind of was like
following so i thought like what's the
one thing i could do that would get him
away from her dad and that was like
no it was because he i
he didn't know either oh okay so i
thought having her dad show me his
construction work in the backyard
there's no way genius yeah so he goes
out there and does that and sure enough
her brother stays behind by the way guys
before graham continues the story macy
doesn't post her dad but he's like buff
he's like he's a scary looking guy so
anyway you guys go out and yeah we go
out and i ask him like how because he's
doing work in the backyard and he talks
for like 20 minutes about to work in the
back here i didn't care at all about the
work in the backyard but i'm nervous so
like i sit there like uh-huh uh-huh
and i'm like yeah and he's showing me
all this stuff it's like really deep in
the conversation about like his
construction work and uh like there was
a moment in the conversation like
actually i
didn't ask you to come out here for that
after 20 minutes after 20 minutes
and uh yeah it was just it was it was
scary i mean he reacted really well but
uh and he was happy but that's so cool
man yeah that's amazing have you tried
your parents
uh
[Laughter]
i'm not surprised no no i haven't i i
will find out at the wedding invite him
over for a dinner oh it turns out it's a
wedding i'm getting married i'll tell
them before so they're not gonna like
see on social media you know i'll tell
them before okay so they'll know about
it before we post this or anything yeah
all right graham that's a really
interesting point but i think you and
jack should tell us about our sponsor
but first we gotta thank our sponsor
ftxus you guys may have noticed that
crypto prices have gone down and that
might mean it's a good time to buy but
finding a reputable trustworthy exchange
isn't always easy that's why we think
that if you're buying and selling
cryptocurrency do what we do and use ftx
us we both use ftx and we just love how
easy and simple it is to use look i'll
show you how easy it is to buy crypto
i'll do it right now yeah all you got to
do jack is select what you want to buy
how often you want to buy it how much
you want to buy and then swipe right and
you're done and best of all when you're
buying crypto and nfts all the other
exchanges basically tack on huge fees
and what do we think about that these
are bad fees are very bad but ftx there
are no fees whatsoever seriously guys
that is like unheard of in the crypto
world to not be charged fees amazing
plus you could get all the way up to a
hundred dollars worth of free crypto
when you sign up using a link down below
in the description plus free crypto on
every trade you make over ten dollars
plus they're one of the biggest
exchanges in the world as trusted by
millions of users and guys between you
and me graham can't know this but
they're soon launching ftx stocks so
it's going to be an all-in-one inclusive
crypto nft finance stock trading app and
it's going to be amazing you guys should
definitely check it out they also allow
for automatic recurring buys that you
could dollar cost average to the markets
on a regular basis so start trading
crypto and nfts with no fees today with
the link down below in the description
on the ftx app again use the link down
below in the description for no fees and
now with that said let's get back to the
podcast so we love doing these midweeks
and we want to scale the podcast we want
to bring more value we want to connect
with you guys on a deeper level and i
think one of the ways that we can do
that graham came up with this idea a
little bit ago he pitched it to me and i
was a fan was of doing a patreon for the
iced coffee hour so the first tier i was
kind of thinking uh we would do
something like producer credit and just
give acknowledgement to people who
support the podcast so at the very end
just like you see like a reel from
movies you'll see a reel with all the
people who have gotten the first tier
and we could just you know name them out
or whatever they want there could be
there
uh so i thought that would be kind of
cool and then that way they're they're
going to be in for everyone everything's
good in time on the ice on the iced
coffee hour
with credit at the very end that people
could see um the next tier which i think
is going to be really interesting
is uh that they would be able to ask
questions for our guest so maybe what we
could do is set something up where we
get the top five or the top 10 best
questions and ask them and we could even
do it during the midweeks uh these
episodes where for these we'll let them
know in advance who's coming and
give us your questions and we'll pick
the top five or ten answer them and i
think that would be great and we could
give them a shout out as well like this
this uh question is brought to you by
you know mateo from patreon whatever it
is and answer them so we probably can't
get to everybody but the best ones will
do
the one after that uh we're thinking
we're gonna do our best to get these
episodes ready
early so like a day or two in advance so
we'll at least promise like 24 hours in
advance you'll have access to the videos
but we can also do our best where if
it's even like five days in advance or
four it depends because some of these we
film on a saturday post on a sunday so
we can't do it for everyone most of them
are filmed one to three weeks in advance
we could work ahead we could get ahead
they'll have early access to it just a
private unlisted link of the video
um and then here's where things get
great so this was an idea that i had
because a lot of people have mentioned
wanting to do some sort of like get
together or something
this tier would get
everything before it including the
questions the video early
but we would host an event
probably it's going to be in las vegas
maybe los angeles where we
bring people out
to come and hang out with us for the
night and do a fancy dinner yeah so we
would reinvest a lot of that money
back into the event so maybe we could
rent out like you know the bottom of a
hotel or like we could find a cool
warehouse or a cool house cater it uh
drinks maybe like live music or
something i don't know but anyway a lot
of that is gonna go reinvested back into
uh just that event and maybe we do it
twice a year
and i think that would just be really
fun yeah that would be fun to network
with people too yeah that would be cool
and that's the thing so and we rarely
ever like go out and do stuff anyway so
i think doing this twice a year would
give us something to look forward to and
it'd just be a really fun time and we
had the mentorship group and we had that
for nearly it was like two and a half
years yeah but we recently canceled that
out and we're like what can we do that's
similar but it's more structured because
the mentorship group lacked a lot of
structure we think patreon can do that
and i love the idea of like shouting
people out and stuff like that and i
think it would be cool to meet you guys
in person at the the events and
everything and also
if you're of that the highest tier
whatever where we meet on the at the
events we also give you a verbal shout
out right on each video no yeah so at
the end of the video you'll be like also
shout out to jeff roonsville for being a
vip member or something like that yeah
we would do that so that would be pretty
cool yeah yeah and then if you guys want
to sign up there's probably going to be
a link down below in the description
yeah and then those proceeds as well are
going to help fund other things that we
want to do on the channel we want to get
really good with
doing our uh clips doing shorts
and expanding on so many different areas
that
we just need uh more time we're thinking
about doing some ventures on the ice
coffee hour that's that are really going
to level up the game but it does have
more production overhead well we can
move on there's another topic i want to
talk about yeah too uh in the last
podcast both of you were talking about
your side hustles
and alex came up with his uh consulting
business when it comes to recording a
podcast and you were talking about your
ad business yeah and i mentioned hey you
know i don't want to get in the way of
this if if those are your businesses you
know so be it as long as it doesn't
impact like the you know the core focus
of what we're doing
and i read a comment and that was a
really good comment
let me see if i could find it was it
about you taking a certain percentage
and holding
no no no i think let me read the comment
because i think it makes sense
and i think collectively
we could uh
let's see he he briefly mentioned this
to me oh is this an actual serious
proposition because i'm always down to
talk business let's talk business here
okay two things number one everyone took
the comments about the volvo way too
seriously saying i was like they were
like you know first like graham yeah
alex's girl trying to like the volvo
yeah i i i think our sense of humor and
our dynamic doesn't really translate to
people who don't know us
but like i don't wanna you are cheap
yeah but i also don't wanna sell the
vault i mean the volvo was never for
sale to begin with unless it's twelve
thousand dollars that's twelve i mean i
don't have to be but honestly like i
drive that car on a regular basis right
now if i need a car with four seats it's
it's the car i'm driving yeah so i don't
wanna sell it doesn't make sense to sell
it yeah but i think the dynamic between
us it doesn't translate we have to be a
little more literal so if you're just
watching this for the first time graham
has a volvo alex wants to buy it graham
doesn't really he uses it but he doesn't
really care for it that much alex wants
to buy for like you know two grand
graham wants to sell it for 12. yeah the
fair market
somewhere
and i'm over there you know but i never
wanted to sell it so my argument was
that like hey if it's an offer that i
would be irresponsible to refuse i'll
sell it
and i'm saving up for a house so my
offer was you know if i can buy it at a
price that's irresponsible to turn down
yeah you know
yeah and people are calling me stingy
and cheap and i don't i don't treat you
guys well which i i am stingy and cheap
but i i think yeah as well
very well uh we had absolutely yes when
we had a pool dancer where i heated the
pool
didn't even uh yeah
later but yeah i'm just kidding yeah i
sent them a venmo request so that needs
to be we're going to although we have a
venmo segment today we're going to get
to i want to talk about all right okay
but we'll get on with it yeah so anyway
i know you're going to talk about it all
right so anyway so those comments were
just i mean you could go ahead and watch
it it's not bad but the dynamic between
us we're joking around i mean it's all
good fun anyway but this comment didn't
get me thinking okay
why is graham letting these
opportunities pass him by the secondary
things that jack and alex are doing
could easily be brought in under the
umbrella as a whole combined resources
and conquer i think jack well i'll start
with you jack okay
you offer a very unique segment in the
market that's not being fulfilled
and i think that between you and i we
have every resource that we need to
completely corner that market of
sponsorships in a way that no one else
is doing i'm not going to reveal the
exact business model here but i will say
what you are doing jack every single
creator that does sponsorships would
benefit from i agree and i think between
the resources of both of us me coming in
with everybody that i know and
putting my branding behind it as well we
could grow this as something significant
and you could scale it and you could
hire it out just like you love doing
and i think oh he's there
he's the most striking
do you love jack
and i think
there is a space for us to scale up
extremely quickly with zero overhead
where
i want to say probably we could run at
85 maybe 80 85 percent profit margins
okay start we'll start with things yes
okay of course there's gonna be overhead
you just said i would hire out stuff
correct second of all yeah but eight and
a half but but 80 percent profit like
your overhead would be substantially
less
than the money coming in the overhead is
10
of
gross earnings from
oh well there we go so that's exactly
what it is that's what it will continue
to be is 10 10 and i could realistically
i could get that down if i wanted to but
i
demand quality with what i'm doing and
10 is where you can get a lot of quality
so
i mean here's the thing man
i'm very content with what i'm doing
right now it makes decent money okay
this month's gonna be a lot better than
last month and will continue to get
better i just don't know how much
realistically i need you to partner with
me on this and i do believe that you do
have a good network and you could bring
in a lot of clients but at the same time
to bring in one client for
residual stuff that that goes on
perpetually i don't think that that's
providing me with as much value as if i
were to just cold reach to people
because it's just a little bit of
upfront capital for stuff that lasts
forever that's why i think realistically
i think it would be way more powerful
when you reach out and say this is a
business i'm doing with graham i this is
great but at the same time i also like
to have this thing that is completely
detached from the brand whatsoever
because i have full control over it
which means a lot to me i like making
the executive decisions but here's the
thing you could still have control and
still make the executive decisions
so what are you just the funnel
yeah just just just the funnel here's
the thing jack so what are we doing we
don't have we don't have any split this
house we don't have to be 50 50 partners
okay
how would you split it
probably 75 25. and you would just bring
me leads mm-hmm
i think the branding leads completely
with consulting but i would let you take
control directly bring me leads we can
segment those from my current lead so
it's basically my current client because
my current client's a big one and this
month it's going to do really well and i
wouldn't want to here's the next here's
what we could do your current client we
cut them out entirely that would be
treated as separate because my thought
is that one person here's here's how
it's gonna work we're gonna i'm let's
say i bring in one person you bring in
one person that would be 50 50.
but it's
most likely it's that one person who is
going to make a recommendation to
another and another and another and the
bigger it grows the faster it's going to
grow okay so one person i have already
is independent of everything else 100
and i think that we sign on from here on
out would be 75 25 i'll think about it
okay
yeah you know yeah i think i think by
the way jack this would be
a great business because it's completely
detached from everything else that we
are doing i agree and even if youtube
goes to zero
this business will still exist for so
many people yeah
that's exactly why i started yeah you
know if you do take on all those clients
jack um
it sounds like you need somebody to
organize all that data
okay okay it sounds like you need uh
a server of some sort a server yeah uh
you're just the guy that i'm the guy i'm
the guy so okay you know and uh you know
you might outsource some stuff you might
have some people
you might have to have somebody manage
your database yeah i mean realistically
i actually had a really good meeting
with the other person that i have in on
this right now this morning and we
basically figured out like the next plan
like how we go to the next level how we
outsource everything have quality
control over this and it's actually a
fairly simple business structure because
it's something i've literally been doing
for the iced coffee for over two years
i've done ridiculous amounts of sponsors
right and
i don't know i did them for a pretty
good time during those two years you did
yeah 100
yeah but you were still with me yeah so
i feel like i have a good understanding
of it we know exactly where we're headed
yeah i'll think about that okay and i
think with the team
not only just like you and your side but
just like the overall team
it integrates so perfectly with
everybody in a way that doesn't compete
with anyone we're not taking away any
existing business from anybody we're
creating a new system a brand new
solution that nobody is doing and i am
shocked that nobody is doing this one
thing
oh you know the one downside i will say
is that once people catch on to what it
is the competition's going to go through
the roof 100 yeah i agree and that's why
i was hesitant on mentioning that on the
podcast and also continuing to mention
it but it's a good business thing the
podcast is the most important thing not
my side business i actually met somebody
on friday their creator in vegas
and um
i can't really say what their problem is
but they have the exact problem that
that jack's uh company addresses yeah
and uh i was like you know because i i
was like shocked that
it's an idea how do i i don't
it's an idea where people are going to
be like wow why didn't that exist before
that that doesn't already exist it does
exist
in people's businesses let's say this
there's this creator that has this whole
structure in employees and all of this
but not as an agency it's probably yeah
that is an agency no not as an agency i
agree so so anyway so that that's my
that's my pitch to you jack yeah alex on
the other hand going to be a little bit
tougher because there's only so much
that you could do um
by yourself yeah
and
building out that team is going to be
harder to scale than jax jack's i feel
like it's a little more simple yours
would be more difficult i would say with
yours we go into the business of
production and that's not something that
we could you know that we have to worry
about competition there's already
competition exactly so it doesn't matter
for us what i think what separates us in
this space is just that we're industry
leaders that's the biggest difference
right but yeah there's
we can say exactly what the what the
business yeah but i think there is a
service for production consulting
management data storage all of that in
regards to
video and youtube yeah um
so
it's smaller market but i think it would
be consistent
but it's true i mean it is it is the
truth it's a smaller market
um but i do think there's potential
there so
if you're interested
great if not that's fine too yeah i was
interested um
in seeing what we could do and i think
we have to like
talk about what
what you could bring
to the table well besides this uh this
smile
do you mean besides the smile yeah yeah
besides a smile the smile is already a
huge thing yeah yeah probably like 50
alone is the spot yeah i would say this
similar to jack would be the network and
the credibility of this is what we have
been doing and just
i will say having having the backing of
whatever you would need that we would
have the experience between us to
provide that i will say you did um give
me a little consulting on one of my oh
one of my 100 yeah and
yeah i might not always be the best at
stuff like that but
but you know what on certain things like
that
i think
did you did was that signed
uh we're reviewing on monday so i would
say uh that particular structure could
really benefit everybody in a way that
is much bigger than you would have done
on your own and i and i say that by the
way as as the real estate experience
that i have done and that i've seen that
work that's worked really well so i just
say having that sort of support backing
experience and network would help as
well and similar to jack i mean i
wouldn't want like a 50 50
you know the business better than i do
yeah so i mean you would still have full
control and do whatever you want and if
not no worries on that but yeah i would
be open to it specifically more because
like gosh i shouldn't yeah okay maybe i
shouldn't bring emotions too much into
the into the business thing but um i
also am grateful for like all the
opportunities because i wouldn't have
had those opportunities first of all if
i wasn't in vegas first of all i wasn't
here um obviously like
it's still a business decision and you
have to like think about it that way um
but
um yeah i i just i also think that plays
a part as well so yeah yeah the whole
point that i'm thinking that comment got
me thinking that i think collectively we
could do way more than we could do
individually just like by the way
without jack
couldn't have done the podcast there's
there's no way i could have done it at
this caliber and this quality this
consistency without jack's assistance
and everything that he was doing and i
think collected and just the same thing
could be said with jack jack couldn't
have built the podcast where it is today
without myself and i think between us
we're able to do way more than each of
us individually and i think that comma
got me thinking that in this case that
is true for this that we could all do
way more together
than each of us having a separate thing
and i know that ties us together in so
many different ways
but i think
you know knock on wood
it would be a good idea yeah i agree
with that and i think i want to do some
uh i want to scope out some competition
this week
i was looking at a few companies who's
going to
get inquiries yeah
yeah just because i want to see how
they're structuring their deals how
they're quoting stuff uh what services
are they providing to keep ongoing
revenue coming because one thing that i
did not think about well i had it in the
back of my mind but graham really nailed
it in for me and uh then i'd like i took
off like researching um he said i should
focus more on the ongoing revenue side
of stuff
like ongoing services
and that's kind of what you're doing
because for me i was like i'm so used to
i was in the wedding industry i'm so
used to like one and done like like we
do this you give me x
you know until next time right if you
have something else and so uh when when
he mentioned the ongoing services i was
like you know there's really a lot more
that i didn't even consider yeah because
one and done there's only so much that
you could do and then beyond a certain
point you're going to have to outsource
that and then how do you find a person
to outsource that isn't then going to go
and like
why am i doing all the i just charge
myself and then they're going to go off
on their own i think having something
recurring not only gives the the
customer support but it also helps you
in terms of creating a
predictable stable source of income yeah
i think unfortunately because of that
aspect of the business if i go into
production um i think anybody that
would work
with us would have to have like a some
sort of non-compete because it's so easy
to yeah slip in the business card hey
man just cancel well you would sign a
contract or contract with those clients
yeah you know yeah but you assign a
contract and say you're agreeing to do
this service for one year and that
includes all of this and if you cancel
uh you know you're responsible for the
following three months or like something
like that but uh
you know it's something to think about i
put it on the table that comment got me
thinking
um beyond all the other so it's funny
you have the people either saying like
just the negative comments and then you
have the people really thinking outside
the box here really thinking what's the
next step
so that is bigger than the volvo
but
speaking of the people that get a
surface level idea of like what happens
because then maybe they tune in for an
episode or they you know they stop
watching for a while and they tune back
in i feel like it's difficult for
viewers to get an exact grasp of like
the the level of commitment and like the
depth of all three of our relationships
and relationships that we have with
other people because
they only see what they hear on the
podcast for example like let's say
sometimes i'll i'll critique graham on
the podcast or we butt heads people are
like how could he say this to graham oh
they're like how about the outsourcing
yeah how can you talk like that to his
boss but the thing is they don't realize
it's like i mean i've known graham for
nearly three years he's one of my best
friends we're business people we
wouldn't be good like business partners
if i was just a yes man you know what i
mean that would not work out and i think
that that gives people it gives people a
bad perspective when we do butt heads uh
because it's all friendly banter yeah i
mean like that's just how we talk as
dudes like we just make fun of each
other all the time and like poke fun and
whatnot so but when you see it that's a
very little heart yeah it sounds like an
unprofessional environment but it's like
very unfortunate yeah it's like people
come together to have fun and yeah but
you know how i remember you mentioned
this a couple episodes ago you're like
it's bad because you see it more as a
friend than you see as as a business
partner yeah and i do i do i agree 100
i see it first as friends and then
second is business part so you know
that's also very dangerous in a lot of
situations if you you know befriend
people that you're working with because
then the emotions of the friendship can
get in the way of the business in this
case i think it actually works at least
with the
with the framework of youtube because
youtube's a very untraditional like you
know business structure i also think it
only works to a certain scale when you
build a team that's that's big enough
you can't be friends with everybody like
it becomes impossible and um graham's
been lucky to like not have anybody that
he's had to fire uh but like that that
would be a very unfortunate place like
like somebody's like yeah i'm not gonna
do the work or like yeah um
you know
like he can't miss an upload we can't
miss an upload like if if anything ever
caused like uh something to miss and
upload like that's a big deal like we
need to be like what what happened and
uh never miss an upload well no that
flat out wouldn't happen yeah yeah but
like let's say you hired somebody and
like i don't know there's people that
don't show up yeah there's people i mean
we had a friend that was talking about
they own a restaurant they were talking
about how they were putting like
sauces on top of like buns like think of
a burger yeah and they're like we have
somebody who would put sauce on top of a
bun and we told him not to do it and
then he goes and he makes a
like a sandwich and he puts the sauce on
top of the bun and i'm just like it's
crazy because sometimes you forget that
there's
people who just don't care yeah and um i
think when you level up a business to a
certain point
you can't be friends with everybody
but luckily i think you're at a point
where it's still it still works but i
agree sometimes it's not for everybody
and sometimes in certain situations it
could be very
detrimental to their business
persistency
yeah is it working i learned a word i do
i do read all of the comments though i
do too and so some of them i do feel
like come from the right place and some
of them get me thinking about things
like oh you know what it's a good point
because i feel like some of those i read
those comments on other people's
channels and even if they're negative
i'm like well they do have a point i
could see their perspective that does
make sense if they did these changes it
would be an improvement so i take the
same approach to uh every channel and i
do read them all and i you know consider
the pros and cons of of that that you
know it piece of advice and i take it
into consideration so i always take them
seriously that's some of the best
feedback you always get is in the
comments some of it legitimately so some
of it you know could be taken either way
but
yeah i see comments like
alex needs to shut up or i see comments
alex is getting a lot of screen time
everyone has different opinions and i'm
just like i'm like jesus christ i'm like
oh my god there were two back to back i
thought was so funny one was
alex is getting a lot of screen time
lately i don't like it and then the
comment right below is i really like
alex on the podcast yeah it's actually
he's you know he's so funny like back to
back
i know exactly what yeah
yeah so sometimes it's like you can't
please everybody or whatever people
really didn't like jack in the very
beginning there's there's some comments
not everybody i remember really actually
yeah i was i wouldn't say people were
like
this
like hated me but i was extremely
controversial so in the beginning some
people really liked it because i feel
like i humanized graham a little bit in
the beginning but some people hated it
yeah you know what i mean some people
talk yeah i think it's because um as you
tell like your stories and people get to
know you uh people start to either hate
or like
yeah like your stories yeah like some
people will hate me because i i think i
mentioned one time that i maxed out my
credit cards to start my wedding
business and i was like 18 and the cash
i had and some people are like well he's
so irresponsible i'm like i know like i
admit it like i wouldn't max that was
out of time
but like it worked at all first a lot of
worked out uh and i was 18. i was like
it was a good experience to learn i and
i would rather have it with like when
you're 18 and like the biggest limit i
had was probably like 10 grand yeah
versus like now if i maxed out my credit
cards i'd be like
i couldn't even pay back everything well
let's talk about some venmo ethics oh no
jack
he's going to spin a story no i'm not
going to spend a story i have some
i have pretty strong opinions on venmo
ethics so i'm the type where if someone
says you know i'll pay for us as a group
i'm the type where i will venmo them
immediately i will ask for the receipt
and i will venmo them immediately they
don't have to ask me yeah because i feel
like they're doing everyone here
definitely not me i will be well we'll
get to that this per this person's you
know stepping up and doing everyone
there a service so why is it also their
responsibility to request money from all
of these people so i'm the type where i
venmo immediately hate it when
i don't i feel bad yeah me too so yeah
there are a few things we need to get on
the table okay last night we went out to
dinner okay graham
created this dinner he said you know
everyone come over to this dinner we're
doing all-you-can-eat sushi no i didn't
say everyone come over i just asked you
guys you have plans for dinner if you
want to grab dinner we could grab dinner
tonight that's all i said and then you
said well i'm with well i'm with andrew
and like somebody else uh i'm like okay
cool but i invited andre over and andre
said but andre earlier to the pool and
then andre said i'm not free and i was
like well maybe andre could just meet us
who organized it
i just asked if you wanted to go there
that's not an organization
it's not an organism that's not an
organization so you created it right it
wouldn't have happened had it not been
for you
and we all go out to this
all-you-can-eat sushi bill sushi place
sorry i'm getting ahead of myself the
bill uh was
270 some dollars yeah change right
and they put the bill down
and graham looks away
and i'm looking at the bill i'm like you
know graham are you gonna pick it up
like i'll venmo you don't worry about it
and graham immediately goes i was
probably about 40 bucks i'll venmo you
jack
and you said okay well hold on i didn't
i i said okay and then i went back on it
immediately afterwards i said okay yeah
wait and then we we talked a little bit
more and i thought i made it clear i did
not want that venmo immediately because
then that means
that i would have to take the bill right
or i was hoping someone else would take
the bill and then i would venmo them on
behalf of both graham and me
so
basically it was 10 minutes of all of us
andre included graham included
everyone's kind of just like dodging i
was watching this you know and it was
now in fairness i was the only one who
was there by himself like you were with
a group of people yeah um andre was with
his girlfriend you're with kelsey my
bill got a lot he was with somebody else
everyone's getting different things i
was the only one who just showed up by
themselves and just got one all he could
eat sushi mine was the simplest thing of
the entire thing everyone else oh and
everyone else not almost pretty much
everyone else got drinks
appetizers uh lucky got like something
else andre got a soju sort of thing i
just got one all you could eat
nothing else people are gonna be
watching this and be like jack's such a
narc he likes like requesting you know
what i mean like and that's not the case
i have plenty of relationships where you
just pay and you know you don't you're
going to say graham should just pay he's
a millionaire
no
no so anyways that's the whole venmo
ethics conversation i figured we needed
to have that so what are the so what are
the rules so for people to follow then
will immediately venmo the correct
amount yes and it is your responsibility
if you're being paid for it is your
responsibility not the other person to
request money from you it should be
immediate and you should say thank you
yes and if they don't do it they're
banned
from ever having that privilege they're
not your friend anymore can you charge
some interest too you should be able to
but i would just say then you never give
them a vendor it goes to collections
yeah it goes to collect yeah you record
you report it to the credit bureaus then
it becomes like venmo banning me like
from doing the transactions then it's
like
cash first man cash first one other
thing i do want to mention just
switching topics here unless you have
anything else you want to talk about is
uh ryan trahan so good oh my god yeah
amazing yeah this needs to come up yeah
so he has a series right now where he's
traveling across america with one penny
to give the penny to mr beast
and initially i'm not into those types
of videos and uh you know the first
three
didn't watch them and then i got in the
fourth or fifth one and i saw like he
posted i'm just curious so i clicked on
it it was a really good video i haven't
watched any of them oh my gosh i've just
seen everybody talking about him and
i've seen him do an interview yeah but i
have not watched them yeah uh so i
actually it actually started with the
culinary and samir podcast yeah you sent
it to us yes and i watched that it was
so good just like the way he thinks and
his i love how he has very low overhead
it's just him and two other people and
he doesn't do these expensive videos and
he's he's getting more views
by
spending like 50 bucks in a video and
other people are you know making
spending 500 000 on a video and i loved
his philosophy on everything and he's so
positive and that got me curious when
his next video popped up i watched it
was so good and now i've been watching
every single one of them and i'm
invested in this yeah like it's so good
and the fact that he posts a video a day
in that caliber is shocking
i'm curious how he's doing it um my
guess is three days ahead it's not real
time yeah i know i i mean i knew that
but uh my thinking but still he can't
miss a day because if i mean i guess he
can have an editor edit for the entire
day because yeah but the thing is if
he's doing every day con
consecutively it would wouldn't make a
lot of sense if you just took a day off
to chill and then get back to i mean he
could but he could do that but my point
being every day he's doing something so
my guess is he's filming with one other
person because some shots it's someone
holding a camera other shots are just
him
and then my guess is the other guy is
probably working on editing while
they're sleeping so that the next
morning they review
and then post and they start it over
again him doing this for 30 days and
it's got to be like the like the logan
ball thing where he had his editor in
the uk and while they were sleeping
they'd uh send him the footage yeah
the next morning they'd have pretty sure
they all traveled together
so he could be on an opposite sleep
schedule like no it doesn't matter
because they're three days ahead so i'm
saying it's like let's say oh it's like
there's some point in the day and it's
you know it's thursday and they're
editing monday's video he can literally
edit the entire day because he only has
to edit one video oh that's true yeah
maybe while they're out there
editing and at the end of the night he
probably just meets up with ryan they go
over the video and boom they post that's
true that's a good way to think yeah
that makes sense yeah but yeah the
series is incredible i've been watching
it ever since the beginning shout out
paul dodds because i know you donated
like a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars or something like that which is
insane no i thought it was fifty one
thousand oh you just wait donate four oh
yeah yeah you did a hundred thousand
yeah he said tattoo time what did he
donate for uh well if you donate you get
like perks for example if you donate
fifty thousand dollars you suffer from
the thing called the great reset yeah
where ryan goes from whatever um balance
he has at the moment
one penny and he has to reset back to
one penny and then if you donate a
hundred thousand you get a tattoo on
ryan or whatever whatever you want to go
the money is going to the feeding
america foundation or something like
that also genius and if you do five
thousand dollars you get a verbal shout
out if you do one thousand dollars your
name gets added to the post rolls
yeah wow you know what we could do we
could do five grand as the iced coffee
hour would you would you want to do that
what is the five grand
just shout out a shout out i mean you do
it for defeat america that would be kind
of cool though yeah yeah
that would be cool gosh a hundred grand
for a tattoo yeah i was gonna say that's
kind of cheap honestly but yeah i mean
part of me wants to do that it's a lot
of
is money what else are you going to
spend on has anybody gotten him a tattoo
yet
what have you what if you got him a
tattoo of like just graham stefan
honestly i don't know if i'd want that
right what about your instagram gp stuff
what if i change my instagram handle
does he have to just
yeah
all right anyways that's a great you
know what someone could get a lot of
benefit i'm not saying that he would do
this or endorse it but if someone were
to pump a crypto yeah
was doing a whole bunch of advertising i
guarantee with creators they'll get way
more exposure for way cheaper donating a
hundred grand to ryan train to get a
tattoo of floating probably cost nearly
100 grand to sponsor one of ryan's
videos anyways and that's like a legit
cool thing that's gonna be there forever
you know you know what the he's not
doing sponsors in his videos no not
these no
that's interesting yeah you know what
probably because the amount of time but
they could do it they're three days
ahead
i think it just has to do with making
good content and i don't think ryan's
necessarily caring about how much money
he's making at the moment he's just
building a crazy empire yeah he's going
to hit 10 million subscribers
a day yeah i know when i see a social
blade it's like unheard of to see that
like mr beast was one of the only few
other creators who was doing that many
subscribers that fast
and ryan trahan's doing it for a
fraction of the budget i like that
yeah i think he just has an incredible
ability of storytelling yeah he's just
so good because you feel like you you
know everything that goes on in his day
you know and he doesn't he never lacks
context he never provides too much
context or is redundant he's just very
good at storytelling and narrating
what's your price with her tattoo on
your body
i i just really don't want to
i
of what right
yeah it really depends on somebody's
name somebody's name where on me and how
big uh
what is this about
that's like nine inches
keep telling yourself that that's like
three inches okay so where are my body
uh
let's say your arm
like right here yes it's visible uh no
or uh here
up here okay so right up here it's a
name also what name is it is it like
tony or is it like like it's a regular
like like regardless or something alex
java like a regular name i don't know
about that one first name or first name
last name uh
okay first name first name okay so it's
just alex
yeah okay i would i would do that
for probably a hundred grand yeah
girl maybe i don't know
i don't know if i'd feel like just like
bad about myself for taking money just
to put someone's name on my mind there's
gotta be a price there's got to be a
problem oh man i don't i just feel bad
about keeping the money yeah but you
could feel bad in a bigger manner the
money's coming from anywhere
i know but it's like but feeling like
i've sold a part of myself to somebody
else like they'll be there forever for
my entire life yeah but there's a price
right
everybody's got a price 10 million i
don't know logically
i'm thinking like a hundred grand just
because of like
only low effort yeah it's just first
name like an alex
realistically probably like
if someone offered me 500 i'd probably
consider it
i don't know but it depends who the
person is and the context like if are
they a good person
and are they just the first are they i
know but are they but i'm gonna be i
know the association with them i know
who paid me are the are they a bad
person is it do kwan and he scammed
everybody and he's paid me 100 to get
you know his name it's like a it's like
your most loyal subscriber
who just graham fan dgb antho yeah yeah
these guys jeff ruins and they just
happen to have a whole bunch of money in
the lottery he wants to get you to
tattoo dgb somewhere oh no that's harder
because you know dgb but like you know
i know mateo too i mean
you know just yeah
we're spending too much time you're
saying
i don't know 250 to a million dollars
depending on what about you next uh
realistically probably like 20k 20k
that's good yeah as long as it's not
like a giant name like giovanni or
something like really long or yeah yeah
i wonder at what point does that just
become fun money because you know if
like a billionaire's out there be like
bet yeah let's go yeah well i have to
say if you're out there i'm not at the
point where i could just be like taking
you guys up in the offers and be like
all right hey 20 grand let's go do that
right now i don't know i think you are
like steve no i think steve will do it
well here's the thing you don't have the
platform to monetize it right no it's a
waste i mean when i think when i think
20 000 just spending that on a tattoo
sure but then i think of all the other
legitimate things that you could do with
that money
and i
i mean you could just give me the 20 000
and then i could use it to like you know
buy a house i mean
a lot of other things that i could do
but yeah but then i just think it's a
waste and like what i l would 10 years
ago me look at that and think that's a
good idea and if the answer is no that's
a good way to gauge yeah yeah i didn't
think about that that's a good way yeah
because because i think the perception
of money will change over time and it's
like you know would that person really
be proud of that decision probably not
then again like 10 years ago me would be
like a hundred grand for a tattoo yeah
take it yeah yeah so i don't know this
both ways
we also have another announcement so i
have a favorite of the logos i like the
black and white one with the coffee bean
as the owen coffee so i think i'm i'm
thinking we choose that what do you
think yeah i want to see it again so let
me what do you think yep i'm going to
wait till graham pulls it up one more
time and um yeah until we take a look
got it yeah that's it i think that's
clean
yeah i agree i think that's it i'm
curious though if we could try this with
a light green background i like that we
like that i don't like the way i do like
the green okay
if anything i'd be down to try a
different color yellow orange or
something like that like what if the
owen coffee was like the bean was brown
no
i like the i like the black and white
but i'd consider other background colors
but not green i think it'd look too
close to bankroll yeah yeah i like i'm
happy with it all right so whoever
designed that logo shout out to them
we're gonna put your name right here and
obviously this doesn't mean we have to
go with this for the rest of the entire
iced coffee hour but i think right now
it's a step in the right direction and i
like it for branding i think it's really
clean yeah and i think it's recognizing
i'll also be contacting them and uh we
said we'd send them some money right
what did we say ten bucks twenty bucks
ten bucks right i think that's what i
know immediately no no like 250 or
something
more than venmo ethics yeah yeah they
have to request it
do the math and all that yeah so i'll
get in contact with you but uh yeah we
love the logo cool so with that said
guys thank you so much don't forget that
you can get a free stock down below
on
instagram and uh thank you for your
sponsors if we have all the way up to a
thousand dollars down below in the
description but also follow me on there
because
because i post every week i post my my
thoughts on the market there every week
so if you want to be a part of it the
link is down below what did you say jack
instagram jls seo alex thank you guys so
much